what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
Chucky season two episode five today I
hear it's a good one John how are you
I'm very excited sir how are you I'm
doing good I'm excited for this ladies
and gentlemen leave a like that would be
very much appreciated also special thank
you to all super sexy rejects those are
the ones who follow us over our patreon
page showing their support really do
appreciate it full interaction watch
along is where you sync up with your own
copy of Chucky available over there
along with a bunch of other shows that
we cover exclusively with reaction
highlights and watch alongs included
your support means the world ladies and
Gentlemen let's see what's going on in
this highly talked about episode
this one is flexi just picture it
jutting out of her heart if that little
[ __ ] had a heart don't you ever say her
name
Lexi's not your mouth
Jagged blade is gonna make him scream
like a little girl
[Laughter]
these are for you and your good buddy
Jake friends
oh he's getting defensive wow
round one fight Chuck how did you get to
be such a wuss I found something better
than killing
don't
[Music]
how did this Chucky murder so many
people you're not good Chucky I am good
check
[Laughter]
you're supposed to be a killer like me
yeah
oh wow
oh no buff Chucky stop it there's
nothing you can do okay just that I can
take each other out
let them take each other out gotta save
good Chucky
Chucky ah Devin just thinks of Chucky's
a Chucky still you're weak
pathetic
you're nothing you're the Chucky no one
will remember that's not true
the word of the Lord
[Laughter]
awesome
[Laughter]
I'm the Chucky I choose to be [ __ ]
yes
Iron Giant Chucky wow he's crucifying
him oh my God
oh my God Colonel Chucky died for our
sins of how he got the idea to crucify
him
oh yeah off camera vomit Killing In The
Name holding up two Chuckies interact
with each other like that going
toe-to-toe
for you coach
how can you just see past even though
it's good Chucky I'd have the hardest
time scene past the fact that it's a
Chucky doll yeah
never trust it he's a killing machine he
saved Our Lives
he saved us from Chucky he is Chucky we
are Chucky but you still have me
I'm not gonna let tricky take you too
there is no good Chucky
huh don't say don't confuse him don't
have this conversation in front of that
Chucky only good Chuck he's a dead
Chucky that was awkward
I would love it if good Chucky is
manipulating this whole thing the
ultimate disguise I would never put it
past them great of course
I find this act of blasphemy deeply
disturbing look at the blood
God damn it
there's a corpse in the closet and a
killer doll on the loose I'm worried
about me
I'm 18.
ouch I had five gerbils
and my mom would tell me that they ran
away
I couldn't figure it out
why would they leave me
you can open the door Lexi
I don't think she ever wanted me to have
any of them at all but
you know how moms are
they do their best to make you happy
right
my mom
she's really good at being sweet when
she wants to be
[Music]
sharing her drug addiction
they're gonna kill her off this season
aren't they
or she might become a killer
[Applause]
[Music]
then just a poop drops in there too
nicely done
you're gonna regret it I already regret
it for you Lexi
the seed
to
remember
you don't want to put that in a text
message you murder people Glenn it's an
addiction have a little compassion
[Laughter]
start with who Nika is and what happened
Mika's my girlfriend
and
sometimes your fathers stop lying
who's Tiffany Valentine I'm not saying
anything until you tell me where Glenda
took Nika all of a sudden you have
nothing to say
Chuck made
Chuck mate please yes thank you sir may
I have another
what maybe it's a miracle
praise be the God what did it feel like
when he killed him
like I finally knew what I was for
holy hematoma Batman the Joker got me
good
and the citizens of God uh oh
Trevor's gone
as I know in the place we left him we
don't know how many Chuckies are out
there what if one found Devin
no he's he's fine he's just being
dramatic and punishing me don't lie to
yourself Jake dramatic
and
who would take Trevor's body though
an ally
or an enemy
uh
uh you would know how could I possibly
convince a believer of Supernatural evil
it must just be a series of violent
elaborate pranks pulled off by some
traumatized teenagers open Leviticus and
read it
read a little bit of Leviticus you can
believe in a man being resurrected from
the dead after three days but you can't
can't believe about a supernatural doll
the Bible's full of Supernatural evil
weren't you the one that recommended
these violent kids be admitted here in
the first place and where have you been
during the reign of terror throughout
these hallways this this sick abandon of
everything holy what what God is trying
to tell them what I am trying to help
them see therapist is totally in on this
in some way and is currently reading the
Bible in the chapel by himself and
that's where he will remain until father
rice is that really necessary maybe
these kids need someone to talk to I
mean are you punishing him for blasphemy
or for Creative prowess why not both
foreign
this is a display of violence and Casual
pageantry Devin is a traumatized kid
this is evil evil
well I did not become a sister to
validate or answer to your fits of
self-righteousness
this is not an Inquisition
this is exactly what it is best none
ever nobody expects the sour Inquisition
I think I can still help him get rid of
that Abomination yes
no one notices the blood nope
looking right past it
[Music]
buff Chucky lives
nice
read the shellfish one next
oh no dude
oh my God he's gonna torch the chapel
oh boy you remember that time in high
school When We snuck out to meet with
the Dean Brothers
what what were their names
you're smart
it was a little long ago it was almost
like we were different people I want to
be Jennifer Tilly yep
[Music]
no way
do you have a check for me
God wait is that
would that be Jennifer Tilly inside the
precious
I'm starving you promised me chocolate
no way she's still alive that's
hilarious
so beautiful that's me I look beautiful
anyhow that's awesome laughs
the ever-expanding lore or could I
possibly give you
guy
I need to convince your sister Meg that
I'm you Meg is here tell me about those
Dean Brothers
yep oh Jennifer plot plot away
I just feel so bad who would do
something like that
are you kidding me
you would do something like that you're
basically responsible for killing Jake's
whole family
for some reason he doesn't seem to care
about any of that because I wasn't his
fault that was a different Chucky he's
not like that anymore
oh my God he looks so upset I
I have to go no you can't
no no child actors no come back adorable
kid
did I really do those things
no that was a different you
there's a lot of you
but you know you're all different kind
of
easy
yeah really
if I came from
from that means that I'm bad too that
means I could hurt you no no
you choose your own identity I know
you're good
what if there's still evil inside me too
wow
like I have an idea
we're gonna need some help
I really like good Chucky I do too
fascinating moral quandary even when we
thought Chucky was dead Jake I mean none
of us ever saw each other ever and I
wanted to talk to you guys
every single day
everything just felt
it's
hard
you guys are a reminder
what's that
is that a doll's foot
what
so you've been
Captain Chucky's breadcrumbs
what you know like Hansel and Gretel
like he's leaving a trail for himself to
find his way back home
gotta follow it
so then the priest usually says
something like
what do you ask of God's church for
Chucky
I ask for a clean slate cool
you could have also just said baptism
you could be my godfather Jake
oh yeah sure
do you want to be The Godfather
ew
[Laughter]
[Music]
I baptize you in the name of the father
keeps me crazy that's a wild
[Music]
and the Holy Spirit
[Music]
cleansing you from your original sin
that's it you're you're clean now
no more evil wow what a feeling
and it was so easy you are very
suggestible
[Music]
I don't know what the hell's going on
awkward
why not
the new Cult of Chucky is formed oh what
are the therapist is from The Cult of
Chucky like between the asylum as a
worker it's a good guess
no
no leave sister Ruth alone you will
believe
[Music]
oh my God that's not gonna work call
someone in
I am
risen oh
you are risen indeed Lord and it didn't
even take me three days
how can I serve thee Lord oh God that's
so ridiculous
there's a new cult in town
Cult of buff Chucky when you were
talking about the Dean Brothers earlier
it really brought back some memories
they wanted to raise money for or even
if they grew up and so they got the
whole band back together and then the
cops were acting in for their unpaid
parking tickets but they still managed
to play The Palace Hotel down the hutch
they still managed to save the orphanage
yes but that is the plot of The Blues
Brothers
that's very familiar
yeah
[ __ ]
excuse me
I have to go okay Jennifer it's a great
plot beat you tricked me you little
troll huh
I don't know what you're talking about
disgusting little sweaty pants aren't
you I'm going to make you sorry you ever
were born oh no
I used to be the most unhappy dolly in
the world Mom oh no oh no
it's not what it looks like Jennifer Meg
it's me Jennifer in here I'm in here
now what looks like what is going on
here
oh my God Meg is so dead yeah oh my God
yep no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no
[Music]
ugh
did she die like this in Psycho too is
that what this is
so ridiculous
rest in peace it will be missed
what have you done you've done
he was my sis
Destiny Valentine and I'm your goddamn
mother
is coming to her own damn
this is Jennifer Tilly's season it's
about time it's really doll is Jennifer
Tilly she gets to play Jennifer
such a mind Bender
kill you mommy's here you
Maniac you
[Laughter]
I am trying to have an important
conversation with my child if you don't
shut up I won't lock you down here to
start do you understand me no more shut
up
foreign
never good at being Jennifer Tilly and
I wasn't that good of a mom either you
don't say look at you yeah and he did
the same thing to you kids also
[Music]
I have one last birthday present for you
no [ __ ] you got the doll yeah
I thought they transfer they transformed
not a transference
[Music]
I thought it was like
Jen gave birth to twins
yes
no It's gotta be the doll
we just gotta get Billy Boyd back
wow
full circles man it's me
kinda
it's for them too
I need to show this to them
let's go get them
okay
alone I need to show this to them alone
[Music]
no no no no
[Music]
so kill Jennifer Tilly
they did take Jennifer Tilly how good
oh my God we are
Seed of Chucky and that's
full seed full seed ahead
[Music]
it's really a trail
uh or just a spot for a bunch of dead
Chucky
whoa
is Andy like living out here tribal
style every dead Chucky's win right
but why was that Chucky taking photos of
stuff if it was Andy
maybe lead the trail to him
there's your boy
holy [ __ ] Andy
what
how'd you recognize Auntie yeah
seriously I didn't even recognize it
from that Sean looks more like Jesus the
therapist is in on it yes
[Music]
Charlie
that's
carnal to you
[Laughter]
thank you
wow
wow
what a cool episode
that
Falls it's not the same ball Chucky
from the first step the first episode of
the season I think it is
it's the same exact one
he didn't have that voice he's just
doing another brand new impression right
Apocalypse Now yes absolutely it's a
brand new impression
I mean it might be a different ball
Chucky or maybe just bald Chucky has
slowly devolved into Marlon Brando
oh that's funny
Chuck of Darkness all right take it away
John now this is a blast good to be back
among the uh you know the main cast and
whatnot back at the school but uh I
liked the the blending of things out of
the last episode we certainly got back
to the main plot line but everything
with Jennifer Tilly and just the I know
people get conflicted about seed of
Chucky's camp and it's you know kooky
metatone and and the comedy the overt
comedy that takes hold when you're in
that world's aesthetic but uh I I love
the way that they continuously just
Kaleidoscope the lore outward and yeah
now you have you know direct
confirmation like okay
keep it Jennifer until he's all trapped
here and that makes a lot of sense as to
how she's able to live this life and so
it's like it serves a practical uh a
practical uh purpose but also you know
adds to this the crazy weird ever
warping blend of characters these people
get to play uh you know because there's
been so much made out of like uh Fiona
duraf getting to do just like every
possible iteration and now it seems like
Jennifer Tilly is also getting that
opportunity
come full circle and it was so cool to
hear her
it's like you really realize how much of
a character she puts on be like because
she's playing Jennifer Tilly you know
it's heightened or she's posing as
Jennifer Tilly and and you're in this
show you know it's heightened but like
hearing Jennifer Tilly's voice
protesting back really reminded me just
how much of a character Tiffany is at
all times and so uh yeah I love that
detail having Meg be the one it makes
perfect sense like it's a fun gag but it
also serves another practical uh purpose
where yeah she's the one who's like
something's off here you don't seem like
the Jen I know and I love that they use
that to their advantage you get a fun
kooky death with her uh and then yeah
cutting back over to everything else
here you know you've got Jake
slowly falling into the Trap of good
Chucky which I'm really curious to see
how it plays out I mean I think probably
everyone's a little sus at the moment uh
for good reason but uh yeah I I really
enjoyed the blend that this episode
episode made because the stuff with the
school is appropriately foreboding and a
bit more serious in tone and then the
stuff at the Tilly house is uh you know
tense certainly but you know zany as
well so uh yeah I really enjoyed
especially on the heels of such a deep
dive into a particular idea and meta
concept last week I really like this as
a return to the overall big picture
and uh in confirmation that nobody dies
if you don't see it happen for Andy so
uh yeah what do you think sir
uh yeah I think that this was uh to me
this is probably my favorite episode of
the Season thus far I think that it has
the perfect world building of everything
I really enjoy about this Chucky
franchise and it's pretty awesome to see
just how
because what the Chucky franchise it
really seemed like there was a certain
set of films
and then you had the camp era of the
films then I was like we got to go back
and take it a little more serious and be
very
horror-centric and something that just
feels more serious basically something
scary again and then to have this show
where it just has this great Collision
of events where it doesn't feel at odds
with with the franchise it feels like it
actually honors the franchise in its
totality because they're doing
everything that I love about the
franchise even the crazy campsite but
they're even converting some of that
camp stuff and making it more serious
like when you compare I think the death
of red man or uh Jennifer Tilly at least
the presumed death and the circumstances
of the the interaction with real life
celebrities
in their in that movie seat of Chucky it
that just registers as totally goofy you
know it's like super silly he didn't cry
when Britney died no no that wasn't the
real Britney Spears that was an actress
pretending to be Britney Spears so when
when basically with that film it is very
it's very goofy and then my point with
that is while like the last episode we
had like Joe pantaliano like them dying
is Goofy
they had mag Tilly here and until I
pulled myself out of the you know moment
to be like this is just kind of crazy
because they got Jennifer Tilly's sister
to appear here and now they're killing
off Jennifer Tilly's sister yeah yeah
and it's not like the way you would feel
in seat of Chucky it's not like the way
you would feel in even a movie like this
is the end you're taking the moment
serious like it's a real character death
and and it has repercussions of a reveal
for
um Glenn in the room to be witnessing
this and for the Revelation that my
sister is in this this doll and trying
to process all this information and what
it's doing to Tiffany and her coming
into her own because so much of her
character portrayal of what Jennifer
Tilly was doing suddenly made a lot of
sense it already made sense but it made
even more sense because it was
revelatory about her character
where she does have that line of I am
Tiffany Valentine and I am your goddamn
mother like the way she Embraces that
and then the the speech where she's
lamenting her whole feelings of why she
wanted to be Jennifer Tilly and how she
really felt like she's just a total
deadbeat she's I think she said I'm a
loser really she feels like I'm a loser
when she's talking with uh with Glenn
and then you're seeing like oh yeah
she's been going like this whole
depression and losing herself and
alcoholism and then one can chalk it up
too she's just she's Tiffany Valentine
that's just who she is she's just kind
of a crazy girl you know but it's not
bad like there is a whole deeper
character side to it so there was
something that felt very much like
coming into her own and an Embrace about
Tiffany Valentine this episode so as
much as we're getting like crazy cool
Chucky stuff you know like with good
Chucky because it could be a ploy it
could be a manipulation but hell the
lengths are going through to if it is
good on them because I've definitely
jumped on the the train that is telling
me that this Chucky is having a real
existential crisis because they do want
to be good I believe it you know like
running off wanting to be on their own
defending you know the the
defending Jake and Devin by trying to
keep like attempting to kill
um buff Chucky like there's there's so
much about that good Chucky that just
seems like that this truck he actually
wants to be good and fears the evil and
fears like
the labeling in the pre-existing
conditioning of where the roots of
Chucky are like it's a fascinating
existential thing to do with the
character and also the the sometimes I
feel like obviously there's some choices
that could be more logical like any
horror thing is it especially in the
Chucky franchise
but I appreciate what they do on a
deeper character moments of how they
make it very nuanced with the
relationship Dynamics because I I enjoy
what they're doing with how you got a
Good Guy Chucky and you got two
different responses from the the lovers
from Devin and how he's reacting to it
and and Jake who's like they're both
empathetic but their traumatic responses
and their reasoning is reacting to this
doll quite differently you know and then
it brought me back to the beginning of
season one where Jake did have a buddy
he did have a friend and it was that
Chucky doll when he was a loner you know
and so to finally have that Good Guy
Chucky doll makes sense to me why there
might be a part of him that you know
when you when you have
sometimes when you grow up in an abuse
you have this certain empathetic quality
that makes you want to see the good in
some one that might be bad something it
can make you do the complete opposite it
can make you totally resistant but it
could also develop this other quality
and
and uh and and I feel like that's why he
really roots for a Good Guy Chucky to
remain Good Guy Chucky so I think
they're doing like all these exciting
things I don't know what this means with
the therapist it seems like the
therapist is in on it in some way she
has to be she she has a bell doll she
has to be she's always been sus yeah
absolutely and I guess Colonel Chucky's
the one calling the shots but but I
think yeah it's it's funny and it's
exciting and it's suspenseful
and they're they're meta nods I think
are
I think they're I like the handling of
the meta nods like this more than I did
the last episode
you know because they they build it into
the universe so well of
like that Family Guy reference I think
is kind of brilliant yeah yeah because
it because it absolutely Works in
Universe yeah yeah you could do this all
remotely you don't necessarily like if
Tiffany needs to go to take a meeting or
something as you can but yeah Jen could
just record all the stuff at home I
think that's brilliant and keep the
fortune some like it answers so many
logical questions and yeah it makes a
real legit I think that's the thing is
like people don't love certain people
don't love the bride and Seed era of
Chucky because it is
you know a bit all caution to the wind
and I feel like here they've tempered it
really well so that it Honors that
Spirit but it's also conscientious
enough to spiral out of like an
interlude like last week's episode and
then yeah use what we brought in clearly
not just for fun and games but for yeah
actual progression of the story actual
expansion upon the lore and I liked what
you brought up with Jake because I feel
like that would be a lot of it would be
I think difficult for certain viewers to
swallow but yeah you have that
relationship that Evan never had you
know or Devin I should say Devin never
had uh he only knows Chucky you know in
the most horrific way possible whereas
yeah you have that Slow Burn of the
first season's start to where Chucky and
Jake are bonding and that's you know an
evolution to figuring out like okay this
is a really bad situation and so I think
it's also a nice way to add yeah some
dramatic tension for our characters this
it makes sense
um and and yeah you know and and plays
on something that you can kind of chart
back into the history of the show to
show that okay this isn't just a way of
going ah what's a new thing we can do it
is but it's also really motivated and I
think that's that's what continues to
impress me about the season is no matter
what wild choice they make it seems like
they've also really thought it all
through and that allows I think the
traversing of tones so you can have
stuff that's wildly outrageous and funny
and then you can have stuff that is
actually like scary and tense and that
does make you wonder and yeah I'm with
you I'm like I hope good Chucky is good
because I think that making that be a
real thing as much as it would work for
it to be a ploy making that real does
feel like a new and interesting thing to
do with Chucky that we haven't seen done
before and part of this franchise and
especially part of the show is anybody
who gets to be a Chucky kind of gets to
now twist through every possible version
that that could imply and I like that
yeah they've done that with Fiona duraf
they've done that with Jennifer Tilly
and now even here they're doing it with
Chucky himself and that gives you know
Brad duriff a chance to change up his
voicings which has happened in the past
but I think is especially notable here
uh as he you know brings these different
Chuckies to life and whatnot and and
yeah like I I love the addition of that
I can't imagine good Chucky is going to
make it through the entire season the
whole like baptism thing like it's so
wild and so absurd and uh and yeah it's
it it it plays on the aspects of the
Christianity angle to the season that
they've brought in in a way I never
really would have thought of or expected
and it you know it asks very interesting
questions and now I wonder you know what
will happen in the rest of the season as
you have Tiffany embracing herself
coming into her own letting go of her
Jennifer Tilly Obsession to a degree uh
and you know going back to to her self
her own motivations and then you know
these iterations of Chucky most of which
are you know the one she definitely
knows but you know you've got this one
and I wonder if they will ever cross
paths and what that could bring to the
table moving forward so yeah like I I
love both the focus but also the sort of
wild possibility and I think they've
really managed to like you said
acknowledge the series in its totality
and to not even like I know Don Mancini
doesn't like as much the voodoo angle of
things but even that like everything
that's come before seems to be
incorporated in a way that's
conscientious and it doesn't feel
ashamed or displeased with any
particular element it has to work with
it just knows how to properly embrace
them in a way that doesn't fully
undermine the fact that this is still
you know horror and stuff but also you
know really Embraces that fun and uh and
just a wild Spirit are in the DNA of
this franchise yeah yeah I think with
the church thing it started to really
click for me the angle of what they're
doing within the church because I've
been wanting to really get a good grasp
of
why why the church setting what they can
do other than the most obvious thing to
predict would be the uh you know
homosexuality is it Abomination yeah
because of Jake and Devin's relationship
so that again uh but this episode really
put the perspective uh into a much more
clear light of
no it's the cult it's the cult mentality
that this this season is dealing
obviously Mancini
has an interest in cult and has an angel
fascination with cult
and this really like the example to me
like the baptism was a case of
brainwashing where it's like a literal
form of brainwashing all over again it's
washing like if we do this this will
convince this person that they are
good and then you have the nun who sees
for some reason projects who Christ must
be unto buff Chucky
and then decides I will obey just
because the song rise out of a trash
just because it's a miracle of some kind
yeah it's it's very and then also the
you're seeing with Devin sawa's uh
priest character the
stringent self-righteous ways he goes
about
um reacting and responding to things
like the only one that doesn't feel like
a cultish like character is the I don't
know
yeah yeah she's she's she's great and
feels very relatable and of course I got
Alexi and Nadine and I like I like what
they're doing with them having like a
genuine friendship you know that's
something we didn't really get I don't
remember of Lexi having just a real
friend
and them being able to be there for each
other and I appreciate the discussions
even though Lexi and Devin have of you
know yeah they were bonded by trauma but
when sometimes when you're trying to
move on that trauma just seeing that
person could be a reminder even on a
very subconscious level that just brings
you back in an emotional mental way
so
to for them to interact not be
interacting makes sense because they're
all trying to move on in whichever way
that might be whether that be drug
addiction or I'm trying to form a
relationship with my my new brother
whatever it might be but then of course
it's the
the Catalyst of another
dramatic inciting incident that unites
them it's like they're bonded by trauma
and I think there's a lot of I think
there's a lot I I guess that's the
bottom line of what I kind of get at
with I don't really say it's about the
movies I mean some of them there's
deeper [ __ ] for sure I will definitely
give it that that's there's often
sometimes there can be a deeper
commentary or something more interesting
to explore a theme yeah I think this
show
um does something very impressive for me
where they keep the entire Spirit of the
movies that preceded it very much alive
but do something much more nuanced as
they move forward without it feeling
like you're talking to me you're
actually still doing a real story and
you're keeping the energy
involved so yeah I think it's very I
think it's really well done and I
thought this episode was one of their
best so yeah
alrighty guys well what did you think
about Chucky season two episode five
we're not able to watch these and it was
at the very end of the video most of you
guys will not get this message we're not
able to just get access to it um
properly until like Thursday so I
started coming out on Fridays so sorry
I'll just hit up 3C films and see what
he does
he's the Chucky he's the Chucky midnight
Pacific Standard Time don't get how he
does it it's very impressive he sneaks
into sci-fi headquarters the shows that
people are like wow you got this out so
fast I'm like yeah I can't figure it out
for Chucky it's the one one show I'm
having the hardest time with it
um leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that Bell leave a like
and let's send this with a patreon
Andrew Hayes Andrew it's Thanksgiving
month so I wanted to give thanks to you
for